welcome back to cbs this morning
republican lawmakers in the white house
are still
struggling to finalize the new
coronavirus relief bill
millions of americans depend on a 600
boost to their unemployment benefit
that is effectively set to expire
tomorrow that's july 25th for most
people
republicans say the additional payment
discourages work
democrats say a cut could be devastating
for those who live from benefit check
to benefit check nancy cordes reports on
the possible
impact on families it's survival
for people that's really what it is
roughly 30 million americans will be in
limbo this weekend
not knowing if they're about to lose 600
dollars a week in federal jobless
benefits they've relied on since april
so you'd be going from
847 dollars to 247 dollars a week
yes one of those people is travis smith
and can you make ends meet on that much
money
i mean i'm thrifty but i'm not that
thrifty
smith is a cook in new orleans he and
his wife michelle
lost work in march with four kids at
home
people are not just sitting around
waiting on the check flicking
channels just to see what's coming on
soap operas they're all hard-working
american people
out here that will love to go back to
their jobs for months
republicans vowed the benefit would not
be renewed
i don't think we will extend the bonus
for not working
on thursday many still had reservations
i would not support something that would
pay
on unemployment more than you would earn
if you were working
but with one in five american workers
still
out of a job the trump administration is
now searching for a middle ground
if you were making 300 dollars you're
not going to get 600 dollars
this time and that's fair people people
understand that it's very difficult to
find people that want to work right now
carol fletcher is a recruiter who helps
companies fill
jobs in central new york she says the
600 dollars
does make hiring tougher do you think
the problem would be as bad
if people were getting let's say 300 or
400 dollars
a week it would not be as bad right now
600
is a lot of money to people especially
people on minimum wage travis smith says
it isn't the money that's keeping him at
home so many
people are getting infected once they go
back to work so it's like health risk
from seeing the numbers and seeing the
data
that is just kind of scary to want to
infect myself and bring that back home
to my family
and like so many businesses the
restaurant where he works
is still closed so here's where things
stand on capitol hill
right now democrats want to extend this
600
benefit through january republicans are
still
finalizing their position so at this
point it does appear that there will be
at least a short-term
lapse in these benefits americans may or
may not
get that pay retroactively if and when
congress does strike a deal
anthony yeah that's going to be a tough
moment for for people nancy for a lot of
people that's that check is what's
keeping them going right now thank you
very much